all right al is wait a minute review al
is next and he's up here I can learn to
push the right button on this phone al
how are ya better than I deserve to be
mr. ng takes my call I really appreciate
it sure how can I help
oh I love this show ok I'll make this
very brief a couple of years ago I
called borrowed I know I'm stupid
I called ball on a car oh no for my
ex-girlfriend oh my now ex-girlfriend oh
no it gets worse ok so she had a history
of pain at late I've been throughout a
couple of times with past due payments
now she filed for bankruptcy chapter 7
yep so who's liable for the debt you
stupid hmm mr. stupid mm-hmm so I did
some research and I found that because I
called ro not cosine but I have some
rights to the vehicle
no be the name your name should be on
the vehicle
my name is one vehicle my name is on the
contract my name is Johnny are you in
are you on speaking terms with said
chick no no crap so I went to an
attorney I got a consultation with an
attorney and he just told me listen just
go get the car it's your car he's not
paying she fought for Chapter seven
she filed a reaffirmation to keep the
debt and it was denied in the bankruptcy
court yeah I want you to get a second
opinion I'm not an attorney but when you
go just pick something up out of
someone's driveway that starts to sound
like Grand Theft Auto to me and I really
don't want you to end up with the yeah
like a felony or get shot or something
like that while you're doing this and
the other thing is if the if she's in a
bankruptcy there's what's called a stay
on all creditors and injunction on all
creditors and you my friend are correct
and I think you picking up and repo'ing
the car might be considered an action
against the bankruptcy court and that's
federal bankruptcy court there's two
possibilities here that are really
negative for you I think you need a
second opinion on your attorney they're
like a different one because I think
he's scaring the crap out of me listen
I'm all about taking action and being
bold and all that I'm not about going to
jail and so let's just kind of balance
this out scary what's the moral of the
story never cosign and never ever ever
cosign for your girlfriend